Elizabeth Holmes transitioned from fast
rising CEO to prison inmate begins today
the former tech industry executive
convicted of cheating investors out of
hundreds of millions of dollars is due
to report to a federal prison camp in
Texas later this afternoon now she will
serve her sentence after a judge denied
her request to stay free while appealing
her conviction Janet shamlian shows us
what prison life will look like for
Elizabeth Holmes
we've made it possible
to eliminate the tubes and tubes of
blood one seen as a Silicon Valley
Superstar good luck Elizabeth former
therano CEO Elizabeth Holmes will now be
known as an inmate at this minimum
security prison in Texas
we'd like to see a world in which every
person gets access to this type of basic
testing
Holmes sold a promise of overhauling the
blood testing industry with just a
finger prick every time you create
something new there should be questions
and to me that's a sign that you've
actually done something that is
transformative
but in the end it was all a lie do you
have any reaction to your guilty verdict
here a jury last year found her guilty
of defrauding investors out of hundreds
of millions of dollars she was sentenced
to 11 years in federal prison
homes will serve her time at this
facility 100 miles outside Houston some
1800 miles from her home in California
where her partner and two young children
live it will be devastating it will be
hard but she won't be the first or last
person to go to federal prison while
leaving children at home Justin papurni
is a former white-collar criminal turned
prison consultant what will her life
look like in that facility
in that facility she's going to be
confined amongst hundreds hundreds of
women there is absolutely no privacy
while it might look at times like a
country club the reality is you are
confined you're locked up Holmes
attempted to transform Her Image in a
recent interview with the New York Times
from convicted felons fell to loving
mother saying she made so many mistakes
and there was so much she didn't know
and understand
papurni expects homes to do well behind
bars but says it'll be up to her life in
prison can be disastrous or can be
incredibly productive it can begin to
rebuild a legacy for her her young
children or she can sit in the TV room
all day complaining Holmes along with
former theranos executive Sunny belwani
has also been ordered to pay more than
450 million dollars back to investors
for CBS mornings Janet shamlian Houston